[Music]
[Music]
it's great to see you all here this
afternoon for those of you who don't
know I'm Susan Hockfield the president
of MIT and I'd like to welcome you all
to this incredibly special event we are
enormous ly grateful to our alumnus mr.
Mohammad Jamil for making it possible
for dr. Muhammad Yunus to visit MIT
today he's been visiting with the
poverty action lab in the Department of
Economics and he's giving us this
wonderful presentation on ending global
poverty it's a great honor to have dr.
Yunus on our campus dr. Yunus is
internationally recognized for his work
in alleviating power of poverty and
empowering poor women he's the founder
of the Grameen Bank a microcredit
institution created to provide the poor
with tiny amounts of working capital for
self-employment since it's launched
three decades ago as an action research
project the bank has made more than five
billion dollars in collateral free loans
to five million borrowers in Bangladesh
96 percent of the borrower's are women
and the bank now lends half a billion
dollars a year to the poorest of the
poor while maintaining a repayment rate
of 99% this innovative approach to
alleviating poverty has inspired a
global microcredit movement that reaches
out to millions of poor women on all
five continents through this work dr.
Yunus may well be the most influential
economist in the world dr. Yunus has
kindly indicated that he will take
questions after his remarks and Dean
Philip Khoury from the School of
Humanities Arts and Social Sciences will
moderate that portion of this
afternoon's presentation but for now I
would ask you please to join me in
welcoming dr. Muhammad Yunus to MIT
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much it's a great honor
to be here and Thank You Susan for
introducing me and I'm so happy to talk
about the kind of work I do it will be
very brief I hope it I had more time to
elaborate people tell me that what's so
great about giving such a tiny loan to
poor people so I don't know how to
answer that question what's so great
about giving so tiny loans to poor
people so one idea that came to my mind
maybe I thought people understand it was
better if I put it this way that imagine
a situation where suddenly all the banks
in the world got closed shut down
non-functional what will happen to
people around the world then thinking
about it I thought this would be good
Hollywood story you can build a good
film out of it it will be horror movie
like Godzilla or something for about one
two thirds of the world population
situation is like that for them
financial institutions do not exist
but the horror that it should have
created in their life neither they see
it nor we the people who have banks
around us see it because we took it as a
part of our life but that's what it is
for two-thirds of the world population
doors of the financial institutions are
closed to them so their life has to be
designed other way and when you say
other way it's not a very pleasant way
because we created a world which goes
around with money you need money at
every step of the way if you don't have
the first dollar you can't catch the
next dollar you need a dollar to catch a
dollar and nobody gives them the first
dollar to catch the next dollar and
that's the situation what you describe
as poverty so it's not their fault that
they are poor we simply refuse them the
privilege of getting out of poverty so
when we talk about eliminating poverty
in the world we are not thinking about
some people who don't know what to do in
their life illiterate ignorant and
that's why they are poor
that's not the way it is they're as good
human being as anybody else as
enterprising as anybody else as as smart
as anybody else but simply they are
denied of certain basic amenities to use
their talent use their creativity use
their ingenuity to move out of poverty
so when back in the 70s when I was
teaching in one of the universities in
Bangladesh Bangladesh was going through
a terrible famine famine is a horrible
situation where people die of hunger
just not being able to eat that's not
food so it's not a very pleasant thing
in situation like that teaching elegant
theories of economics writing down all
your equations and so on and telling
students how to overcome all the
economic difficulties empowered by the
theories that we have in our textbooks
that empowerment doesn't get translated
into real world
just outside the classroom where people
are going through this experience of
famille so that's what took me to out of
took me out of the classroom and trying
to see is there something that can be
done and out of those tiny little things
one thing that I confronted not noticed
in every day way that how people
suffered for tiny little money and then
I took a student of mine went around in
the village to kind of list people who
had to borrow from the moneylender and
when our list was come
cleated there are 42 names on that list
who took money from the moneylenders in
the total amount for the whole 42 of
them was $27 so again imagine professor
teaching in the classroom about the
five-year development plan for the
country all the millions of dollars and
billions of dollars you need to invest
to overcome the poverty in the country
has no idea that few meters from that
classroom people are not waiting for
those millions and billions their life
is going through a miserable condition
because of few pennies less than a
dollar so my first response was to get
$27 from my own pocket and tell them
please return the money to the
moneylenders and work whatever you want
to work with with this money and be free
in that sense of liberation that came to
them hooked me on I asked myself that if
you can make so many people so happy
such a small amount of money shouldn't
you do more of it so I was thinking how
to do more of it I could give more money
from my pocket but I thought that only
solution ultimately I was thinking more
something which will be generating a
system so I thought I should link them
up with the bank which is located in the
campus which I tried when I proposed to
the bank manager he literally fell from
the sky
he couldn't believe that I am saying
that he has to lend to these people this
tiny amount he are good very forcibly
that it bank cannot lend money to the
poor people poor people are not bankable
poor people are not credit worthy he
made all kinds of arguments which didn't
make sense to me so I made art my
arguments it's a no-go situation either
side so anyway the long story went
continued for several months meeting all
the government of the bank officials
trying to see to persuade to take loans
from the people for the people
nobody would agree ultimately it was
solved by offering myself as a guarantor
I said I'll sign all your papers since
your rules require it and you cannot
accept them because they don't have the
collateral and the banking system is
built around the collateral so only way
I can do it is to offer myself as a
guarantor that still took another couple
of months of correspondence and
discussions and persuasions and finally
it was resolved and it started giving
loans to the people in the village bank
managers said you can say goodbye to
your money this is not going to come
back I said I'll take a chance I took my
chance and along with it I tried to make
some simple rules to encourage them to
pay back and it worked I got very
excited that it worked because bank
manager said it don't work
when I came to the bank manager to admit
that everything is complete all the
money came back he remained totally
unimpressed he said maybe you did it few
people in one village a professor can do
all kinds of miracles in one village we
don't take it seriously so I said what
should I do he said you should do it in
two villages I said okay although in two
villages I did it in two villages it
worked beautifully but he remains as an
unimpressed as he was so this is the
story I go on doing it and he raises the
number of villages and after I have done
it several times then I don't on me if I
do it for the whole world he will not
change his mind because his mind is made
banking cannot be done with poor people
and I cannot undo that mind I said if
now he says poor people are not credit
worthy they are not bankable I will
scream I'll scream at the top of my
voice said that's a lie that's not truth
because I have done it I've seen it I
said real question is not whether people
are credit or they are not the real
question is where the banks are people
were thick and they are not so I thought
maybe I should now create a bank which
is different from the banks that I know
and I've made a proposal to the central
bank that please allow me to set up this
bank which will work for the poor people
central bank says I never heard we never
heard of that kind of backed it doesn't
exist you better go to the government so
I went to the government
again a long story finally we persuaded
the government ultimately and we became
a bank in 1983 we were so delighted that
finally we got ourselves a bank for the
poor people so what is the difference
between the Bank for the poor people
and Bank that we know the conventional
banks the basic difference is the
conventional banks are built around the
principle that the more you have the
more you can get which meant if you have
little or nothing you get nothing and
that's why two thirds of the world
population don't get anything so we
reverse that principle in designing our
time our principle is the less you have
the higher priority you get if you get
if you have nothing
you get highest priority and we think
that's what the banking should be after
all people who don't have anything they
should be the one who should be getting
something to get it started and then
people said it may work in Bangladesh
but it will never work in anywhere else
Bangladesh is a funny country all kinds
of funny things happened there so maybe
this is another funny thing well luckily
many became interested in our experience
they want to do it in their countries
and gradually it came out in Malaysia in
Philippines in Indonesia we are very
happy that's working in other countries
today after all these years Grameen Bank
works all over Bangladesh we have five
over five million borrowers right now
96% women we lend out
over a half a billion dollar a year in
tiny loans averaging about $120 right
now the money that Len we lend out comes
from the deposits it's not a bank
somebody some people are the donors are
giving the money and they are
distributing that no it's not like that
it's just like a bank is supposed to be
taking deposits and lending money that's
what we do on top of it what we have
done
unlike the banks that we are familiar
with the conventional banks we focus on
women 96% of our borrowers are women no
collateral needed no legal instruments
are needed so there is no legal
instrument between the lender and the
borrower you don't have to sign and not
arise and stamp and you know all kinds
of legal papers we don't have any legal
papers how does it work you give half a
billion dollars and no papers and
bankers tell me can you sleep I said I'm
very peaceful sleep I have no problem
said without papers you gave all this
money what it does if it doesn't come
back I said I don't worry about it
because ever since we created money
always comes back and it still it does
99% and the 1% is not money lost it's
simply not paid within the time limit
that's all it gets paid back to after
the time limit so it's a very happy
situation we have savings people put
money into the bank right from the
beginning we concentrated on the
children of the families of Grameen Bank
these are poor families basic they don't
have any education illiterate families
so we wanted to make sure our children
of Grameen families go into school and
very soon we succeeded in doing that
hundred percent of the
children of Grameen families are in
school today
many of them are in higher education
going to colleges universities medical
schools engineering schools and Grameen
Bank provides them just student loans so
that they don't have to worry about
money for financing their education
there is a kind of discussion or
criticism that microcredit is a great
idea and it's wonderful for the poor
people but it works only for the top
layer of the poor people who have some
entrepreneurship some skill it doesn't
work for the middle level of the poor
people bottom level of the poor people
they need charity they need handouts
because they don't have the enterpreneur
ability they don't have any skill we
scream that's not true because in
Bangladesh when we began our loans are
less than $1 to twenty seven dollars to
forty two people that's our starting
point so these are not the top layer of
the poor people who receive this money
and then we can saturate it on women
these are not the Harvard case studies
or MIT cases studies of entrepreneurship
the women coming and say pleading with
us please don't give me the money I
don't know anything about money imagine
that you go to the bank bank said well
you justify why we should give you back
here we are going to the people to give
money they said please don't give us
money so that's the kind of bank we done
and they became so desperate they were
arguing that please give it to my
husband he understands money I don't
understand money some says I never
touched money in my life so now you tell
me then Trapani
ship skill and so on
we went there deliberately addressing
them and brought them in but still
people go around saying well it's a
great idea but it doesn't work for the
middle and the Lord
so recently what we have done we have
got fed up with this argument we said
only way we can stop this argument by
kind of dramatizing the whole thing we
said let's give loans to the beggars you
can't be poorer than beggars that's the
last stage because one doesn't have
anything else so she goes on the street
beg from people for finding some food to
survive so my colleagues us what do we
do with them
we said well okay let's go and talk to
them one thing we should do find out
when she became a beggar at what point
because this is very important point in
making a transition from a normal human
life to position of a beggar it's not
easy so that we understand her better
and after we have learned all this and
then we sympathize and say okay as you
go from house to house begging would you
like to carry some merchandise with you
some candies some cookies some toys for
the kids and give people option well
they will give you some food or buy
something from you if you're selling
thing picks up you think you're making
enough you think whether you should
switch to selling rather than begging
it's up to you and they started liking
this idea and in the beginning we
thought we may have three thousand four
thousand beggars in the program soon we
came up with fifty thousand beggars in
the program
and excitement of turning themselves
into businessperson you didn't believe
what it means to them and we tell them
look Grameen Bank rules do not apply for
you so don't worry about all our rules
forget it
only thing this is a loan you'll have to
pay back as if you can no interest its
interest-free loan so don't worry about
money growing into big money so take it
and never pay us with your begging
income that's not our money this is your
money all we want if you make money by
selling things then you can pay aspect
if you pay back the loan you'll be ready
for another loan people understood it
very clearly clearly a typical loan for
beggars is nine dollars imagine with
nine dollars people thinking about a
business idea and how to bring herself
out of the begging out of this now that
it's ongoing program we have about
thousand beggars who are no longer
beggars anymore there are business
people I said our success would be if
you can see within a year within six
months three thousand five thousand have
come out of begging they said this is a
what a and what a message for all of us
that people can pull themselves out of
all kinds of situation given an
opportunity so this idea of giving loans
and building up this kind of in a
financing institution caught up globally
and it in many countries is being used
this also led us to think about other
things information technology for
example we thought not only microcredit
is important microfinance is important
information technology is also important
for poor people we got an opportunity
I'm skipping the whole story we created
a mobile phone company called
Grameenphone everybody that's a crazy
idea you are doing lending money to poor
people why do you want a cell phone
company we said we want to bring cell
phone in the villages of Bangladesh and
give loans to the poor women so that she
can buy herself a cell phone and started
start selling the service of a cell
phone in the village and make money who
is going to use the cell phone in the
village I said whoever wants to make her
call to anybody
everywhere artists say it will never
work but it became a rolling business
women took loans started selling service
in the village and many villages in
Bangladesh have no electricity 70% of
the population of Bangladesh do not have
access to electricity so how do you
bring cell phones in the village where
there is no electricity and most of the
villagers don't have electricity we
promptly came up with an idea solar
panel that's it so we started plugging
into a solar panel so now everywhere
mobile phones there are a hundred and
seventy thousand telephone ladies in
Bangladesh selling service of telephone
who never saw telephone in their life
never heard that there's a gadget called
telephone people used to tell us well
you are giving money to the women okay
all she can do all her life is to raise
chicken or make basket or raise a cow
because she cannot come out of that
traditional technology ever so when we
wanted to give Televisa's in no way she
will be scared and I was always arguing
that don't underestimate the
talent of human beings they are very
creative people there is no difference
between the poor woman and anybody else
so that is only something in an idea but
it's wonderful to see that people
reacted exactly the same way
now today you go and talk to any
telephone lady in Bangladesh you can
make a call from here they talk in the
business language she talks as if she
was born with the telephone in her hand
she knows everything
ins and outs of a telephone what a
confident person she is people ask me
what is what is is this that you see as
poverty how do you define poverty I said
I don't know how to define poverty but
to me is something that I see as a kind
of image which comes close to my mind
it's a bonsai tree the bonsai little
tree I see poor people
bonsai people you pick up the you choose
the tallest tree in the forest
it's a beautiful tall tree in the forest
and pick up the best seed for the trait
and plant it in a flowerpot what do you
get tiny little trick it doesn't grow
very much it looks exactly like the tree
you saw in the forest it's a small
replica of that trait is there something
wrong with the seed of the tree no we
picked the best seed then why is it so
small
because we planted in a small flowerpot
we didn't give the tree space enough to
grow so it's not the fault of the seed
is this space denied poor people are
just like that tree they're as good
human being as anybody else simply they
are not given the space so the poverty
is not created by them it's created by
the institution's we built banking
institution is one policies that we
pursue even the concepts that we
designed and we discuss in our
classrooms ultimately impacts on the PIA
society that we create so if you want to
get the poverty out of the world you
have to redesign those concepts residual
design those theoretical structures if
we fix those things nobody will be poor
person because their ability to take
care of themselves is inside of them all
human beings have unlimited potentials
most of us in the world scratch only the
surface and the poor people never even
scratch the surface so the gift each
human being has inside of them among the
poor people that give remains unwrapped
it's been packed it never gets open so
we when we talk about microcredit or all
those things that I'm talking about this
gives an opportunity to make a little
bit of openings find out who I am and
that's the one important thing to see
what is inside of me and how much of it
I can bring out
and if we can allow that if you can
create that kind of society there's no
reason why anybody should languish in
that misery and suffering and one way to
do it I'll quickly stop at that is to
redesign the concept of business one the
business today is understood everywhere
in our textbooks in our theory in a
real-world business mean business to
make money I said human beings
interpretation of human beings in that
way it's a very limited way human beings
are much more it has much more variety
inside of each human being than just
that human beings cross the whole range
of feelings whole range of dimensions
inside of them so I said if we could
include in a basic idea of business as a
two kinds of business like business to
make money is one business to do good to
other people there's another one we can
run business to do good to people these
would be businesses which are not
concerned to make profit but to reach
out to people solve social problems in a
business way these are non lost
companies it doesn't lose money it's a
break even companies could be done and
we can address most of the social
problems in a business way if you can
put them in a business way social
business this we can call social
business if we can make social business
enterprises a lot of problems can be
addressed that way problem of poverty
like microcredit for example can be
addressed that way problem of children
suffering child ever livelihood creation
crimes drinking water sanitation
healthcare in a social business
enterprises we need social business
entrepreneurs people say haha I want to
do this this is a challenge I want to
take I can design things and I can run a
business not for me to make money but to
reach out and solve the problem so this
is a challenge this is an idea what I
think time has come to address
lots of problems that we see around
ourselves and thank you very much I'll
stop here and
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
we don't have much time unfortunately
dr. Yunus has to head back to New York
it's a busy week for him so we have
microphones somewhere here yes here in
there and so if you would please come up
I'm sorry that's the only way we're
going to be able to hear you and if you
just line up and we'll try to get as
many of you in be as brief and concise
as possible thank you please go ahead
it's very inspiring thing you do for all
those people I had a practical question
which is how specifically do you guys
actually run the operation how do you
collect how do you determine how much
interest you charge and how much
interest people get in their deposits I
will have a one full blown lecture for
that it we have branches
we have over 1,600 branches in the
country in Bangladesh each staff is
responsible for a certain number of
borrowers to take care of their needs
and so on all Grameen Bank activities
are organized around building five
member groups five people form a kind of
a business circle and several of those
groups together create what we call a
center the center meets each week where
the business is transacted our basic
principle is people should not come to
the bank bank should go to the people so
we always go to the people every week we
meet all our 5 million borrowers at
their doorstep and do the business and
do stuff and all our loans are paid back
in weekly installments so this is
basically with the operational details
and just what's the average interest
rate you charge people interest rate we
try to be as close as possible to the
market interest rate market interest
rate today in Bangladesh is about 14
percent we have four interest rates in
our work one is twenty percent which is
six percent above the market rate and
the next one is the housing loan housing
loan is 8 percent
which is way below the market rate and
next one is 5% for a student loan which
is again way below the market rate and
for beggars is a 0% so so together we
are close to market rate and we also a
deposit collector so on our deposits we
pay 8 and 1/2 percent interest on
deposits minimum and it goes all the way
to 12 percent so we pay 8 and 1/2
percent to 12 percent and we charge 20
percent 8 percent 5 percent and 0
percent that's it thank you thank you no
thank you dr. Yunus for your comments
and for all your work my name is from
the Fletcher School and we thought that
kind of enthusiasm around surrounding
microfinance right now I've heard it
said as a word of caution that
microcredit especially offered first to
the poor can really cause harm to those
who are in need of it and I'm curious
just as your comments and advice to
those enthusiastic about microfinance
what are you doing and what do you
recommend should be done in the way of
offering other interventions to ensure
that this capital provide to them
doesn't in fact in debt them thank you
one thing to be careful when you give
loans to people we try to make sure that
this money is used for income generating
purposes money should create money once
you consume it up take the money and
then you create yourself the obligations
and the debt burden and all kinds of
things so that's why we created all
those groups and so on you can mutually
oversee each other's activities so that
you don't use the money in the wrong way
because we gave loans for income
generating activity so you have to
demonstrate you have to explain to your
own group members what you are going to
do with the money how this money will
bring money for you bank doesn't approve
the loan basic approval is done by her
own friends so she has to explain
everything what she is going to do so
that they can go and
so this is how one way we see is to
protect them from using up the money in
the wrong way there any other activities
such as capacity building or market
value chain improvements or productivity
enhancement activities that the bank
does along with the lending we don't
have any program of training as such but
we try to connect them with each other
if you are doing something and somebody
else is doing the similar thing in the
next Center which he is doing this why
didn't you get together and see what you
do they learn from each other much
faster and one thing comes because of
some kind of jealousy the she is doing
so good and I'm not doing it so she
would like to be equal to her so this is
also good she this is a creative
jealousy this he tries to get even with
her and proved that she can perform
better than her
it's a neighborly jealousy that works
pretty well we and we encourage we
always give examples of what others are
doing so that she feels she feel how how
could you do that
thank you please one question each I'm a
no follow up I'm sorry everyone a chance
dr. Yunus one Garcia from ICIC thank you
for coming and speaking to us I read
your book felt very empowered than you
but my question is in your book you
touch a little bit about the example of
microcredit financing here in the US
right yeah and it seems it was not as
successful as we had expected so in the
wake of Katrina and with all the people
that behind with nothing how could an
example like yours become relevant very
much I just wrote an op-ed I don't know
if anybody published it yet
mentioning that because Bangladesh has
lots of experience of going through
floods and disaster this is our normal
life we face this all the time so we had
to learn this over time
one of the thing we find it very useful
in a situation of disaster microcredit
to build it back again quickly because
of all the mechanism is set to get you
started all over again put you on your
feet here or saying this will be an
occasion in New Orleans try two things
one is microcredit credit in general so
that people can go back and start their
life all over again build their houses
build their livelihood and so on another
one this is a good opportunity also for
building up social business enterprises
social entrepreneurs coming social
business entrepreneurs coming and
designing things in a business way to
address these issues money going as a
handouts as giveaways sometimes don't
achieve the purpose for which you do but
if you are doing it in a business format
it works much faster and much
efficiently so this is one occasion I
would think would help enormously thank
you many of us are familiar with the
arsenic Christ the drinking water in
Bangladesh and I'm wondering if you have
taken any steps to apply your philosophy
to empowerment of women in providing
safe drinking water yeah we try out all
the time this is a terrible thing that
we have been going through Grameen Bank
has encouraged people to have tubules
we gave loans to have vehicles at that
time we had no idea that this is going
to lead to another kind of problem
UNICEF was so enthusiastic about tube
wells we thought we should have two ball
for every single family in German back
which we generously kind of promoted so
now we feel guilty that this is being
the source of such a terrible thing
arsenic so quickly what we did like
others have done kind of classified
those two balls which are arsenic
content is so high that it's not usable
for drinking purposes which others which
are still usable because arsenic problem
doesn't exist once we have done that
then we have earned a second level where
the arsenic exists
how to clean it up so there are certain
methods now is picture three picture
system which we encourage and them
encouraging them to go into rain over
her rainwater harvesting people are not
familiar in rain water has been
Bangladesh is a country of rains in
monsoon we get enormous amount of rain
but people don't drink the rainwater
because there's water everywhere so now
we are encouraging them to build Jain
rainwater harvesting system and purify
the surface water but still the real
answer has not come arsenic is still a
major problem we are still providing
loans for that but yes no problem is the
technology is the problem right now for
us no we give housing loan they took
same old things we have given housing
loan we have gone to debates everybody
said you don't give housing long because
it doesn't generate income we said no it
generates income it's a very productive
loan if you can sleep peacefully that's
very good this gives you the energy to
do that and for women for women because
our borrowers are women we said the
house is also her factory that's where
she works so if you cannot if you leave
this roof open she can't work so it's
very important so what is productive
what is non-productive is something that
you have to decide in the context of the
situation so simply say drinking water
is not productive it won't be a good
thing to say what kind of results have
you find in impact evaluation related
with poverty alleviation of like with
the loans compared with groups that have
received the loans yeah there are lots
of studies done on Grameen Bank on many
many different issues Grameen Bank
became a very attractive research
subject for for many reasons for women
or credit for poverty alleviation
health and so on so in all this
they have uniformly came to the finding
that people in coming back have moved
out of poverty consistently one World
Bank study tells that gives a very
specific number they said 5% of the
Grameen borrowers come out of poverty
every year and we have been trying to
make sure not only 5% that speed can we
make it faster so that larger a larger
percentage of Grameen borrowers get out
of poverty each year in each month each
day each week because when people don't
wait until the end of the year so get
out of poverty the guys they get out
every day one family today next family
tomorrow depending on where you are so
we want to see that happening there
another study shows that the getting out
of poverty starts as soon as about five
five cycles of loans but there may be
families which takes 15 cycles of loan
is still in poverty so we are trying to
see how to reduce that 15 cycle to come
down to tenth cycle and fifth cycle to
come to the fourth cycle so that range
in between become shorter and shorter
people all kinds of people come and we
see the reason it's prolonged for many
families is sickness disease so the
health became another worry for us we
still couldn't adjust that health issue
and that's we see the challenge for
anybody who's interested in poverty
alleviation how to adjust the healthiest
healthcare services to come to the
poorest people in an affordable way so
that they can get out of the health
problems that they suffer poor also
means poor in health it goes together so
now you have to address it
simultaneously we are addressing one
part but we still couldn't go to get to
the health part so this is where we're
now trying to see can we build in a
common type health care in a universal
way within
to build it up in a way that nobody's
left out of health care system we're
going to have time for a couple of
questions I'm very sorry please so we'll
just go as far as we can with five
minutes okay mister units thank you for
your inspiring talk thank you when you
told your story I couldn't help but
think that the banker you approached
might feel like IBM does after meeting
with Bill Gates I have two quick
questions you can answer whichever you
like you said you'll give me options he
has a good eye you said you had an
original set of rules when you made the
first small leap if you could go into
detail about those rules that you had
for the first 42 of your borrowers and -
do you have any advice for people who
are thinking of replicating a similar
scheme for micro-insurance because given
the disasters that take place people
often lose their livelihoods and we've
had discussions students about how
micro-insurance thank you
yes micro-insurance is very important
thing and let me take the micro
insurance part of it we have been
providing health insurance we have
developed a health care system but in a
limited area we are trying it out I'll
explain a little bit more each Grameen
Bank family in that area where we have
them actually healthcare each insurance
can join the insurance program by paying
about three dollars a year if you put
three dollars a year entire family comes
under the health care agency and for
that you have a fully qualified doctors
in the area and paramedics and health
workers and you can buy medicine at 25%
discount and you have pathological
laboratory a lab right there and so on
so today in the 20 areas that we work we
cover about 90% of our cost in expenses
that we have - intra so I still have a
10 percent gap so we are trying to see
if we can come to the hundred percent
recovery so that we can expand it
globally all over Bangladesh because we
cannot expand it globally if you have to
subsidize it
from the resources that we have so this
is where we are looking for this is the
health insurance part then we have the
loan insurance loan insurance simply if
a borrower dies and she lives behind of
course she lives behind a loan amount
under this insurance entire loan amount
is paid off by the insurance so the
family doesn't have to worry about it
and not only it's a financial relief for
the family it's also a great
satisfaction for the borrower herself
when she's alive because she feels when
she dies she can go very clean to God
she doesn't she has not left behind any
oblique with no obligation because this
is a part of their religious feeling
that if she leaves behind alone God will
be extremely unhappy with her until
somebody takes care of that loan she has
to suffer it so now she feels very happy
that the loan the insurance takes cover
everything's she feels that I have not
been creating any burden on anybody
going am i alive when I am dead I don't
want to leave any burden on anybody else
I can go clean so that's a health sorry
loan insurance another one is a life
insurance we also have life insurance
coverage that so this is lower insurance
life insurance is universal we didn't
come in back it's already there but
health insurance is for just a limited
experimental way we are doing it I hope
we'll be successful
well this has been an extraordinary
afternoon and I want to remind you all
that none of these things happen by
virtue of a single individual and we owe
an enormous amount of thanks to our
alumnus Muhammad Jamil from the class of
1978 for making it possible for dr.
Yunus to be with us today MIT we pride
ourselves by saying we're the kind of
people who solve problems and I cannot
tell you how inspiring it is to see how
one individual through intelligence
initiative persistence has made an
enormous
inroad in one of the world's greatest
problems which is global poverty I want
you to please join with me in thanking
dr. Yunus once again for inspiring
you